I'm not saying you will be forever but
like there's you can't not take
accountability and say I was young she
cheated and she enjoyed it
okay wait wait hold on hold on do you
know what Paul you need to invest in
like a red flag hat so you can just wear
it the red flag hat on us hold hold on
to that one still hurt people hurt
but I don't agree
after dating a bad boy Will Smith is a
perfect example
on and off and um this was my toxic
relationship before and it made me
realize that I didn't want that life I
didn't want it and I went to therapy I
worked on myself I worked on my issues
and I went for a good guy and I have not
cheated on him I will not cheat on him
and we are happy so I don't think that
okay
so I'm not hold on I'm not saying that
you can't date after but I'm saying from
a man's point of view if you could pick
a girl that hasn't had a toxic ax or you
pick a girl that has a toxic ax why why
wouldn't you pick the one that has it
yeah he'd probably say like I had issues
a bit when I went yeah yeah because it
comes with problems and it's not it's
not saying like no girls can come back
from it ever some some do but a lot of
them will cheat because they're not
really attracted to the nice guy I have
seven red flags can we take some off no
no no
it doesn't matter I mean
[Music]
you heard more than that so she took
outside
I mean oh it's 15 years ago so yeah okay
what do we think
okay okay let's let's ask the she's
let's she's very nice you're both
talking account
um everyone but the ladies how many red
flags should she have 10.
we need red flag much
so far
we haven't seen there yeah okay yeah
should we okay okay you know what you
know what should I give Eddie a red flag
yes
I need you to rationalize logically the
red flag that I've acquired okay
rationalize it for me all right all
right to be friends why it's toxic okay
is that
in that situation where you were in an
unknown place okay good unknown and the
guy was sitting down you don't know his
intentions in fact you put yourself in
that situation and you did a good job on
the woman yeah which which could kind of
cause a repercussion in which the guy
could have become violent in that
situation
my point was uh talks is because
there is an element of an unknown that
will result in violence yeah that's true
but there's also element of unknown that
makes it exciting but wait
more than Uber you see my chest brother
you think a man's gonna come and try to
punch me up you think I didn't evaluate
the situation prior listen I'm from the
streets bro when you walk in an
environment you need to know where I go
on what no I mean I mean yeah yeah
okay now now that we've had the
discourse
raise your hand if you think Eddie
deserves a red flag just the three guys
I know we're not we're gonna take the
men's opinion so so you think red flags
no no no okay you need no red flag I
ain't toxic self-awareness with the wave
about his relationship nothing to do
with me not them to
them too but he had nothing to do with
it so he's innocent I was an object
Michael your turn
sorry your turn I can't the only thing I
can think of is we went back and forth
to each other so many so many times and
that was toxic in itself we didn't know
how to separate eight years of back and
forth back and forth when the
relationship was dead from three years
in
so that was toxic I feel like I'm just
gonna put toxic we can yeah breaking up
and getting back together right raise
your hand toxic yes breaking up all the
time and getting back together
Bad Boy energy yes no I hear that yeah
it's toxic yeah
but so what there was an individual
characteristics that you both did that
were toxic within the relationship
arguing because
with me that one one girl that I knew
she was talking she used to cry a lot so
she would cry and that would make me
feel better not oblige you know what
I'll give you a blind so did you do
anything like that like you manipulate
him through your tears or
I think he was trying to do
I I think I took him away from what he
was trying to do he was trying to be a
music producer like most guys are back
in the day you like get a real job
and I was trying to take him away to
kind of focus on having a kid and all
that so I was taking him away from where
he wanted to go to be fair my sister
told me he's actually a really famous
YouTuber now we're not going to go there
but he's done well for himself so I
think uh breaking up was the best thing
that we could have done because he got
what he wanted I got what I wanted
from different people I think you're
removing a man from his mission is toxic
yeah that is yeah I mean I didn't do it
in the sense of you have to choose but
well you came first
no I just think I was on a mission to
have a baby and I even though he was on
the same path as me he really if I'd
listened to him truly that's not what he
wanted he wanted to focus on him and his
music career and I and I was still
trying to kind of I wanted him to do
that but I also wanted the other stuff
do you see a whip how could I that could
have gone wrong though in the sense that
if he let's say you got pregnant and he
wasn't really in it and he left now
society would say it was his fault but
you kind of pushed it on him
know and and I realized that and I
realized that I had to get out of that
and that it wasn't going to make us both
happy and I didn't want to be a single
mom so but at the time I mean I was with
him from when I was 17. it was toxic it
was and and I look back now and I think
I should just said you know what you do
your thing you focus on your music and
you know we'll wait but I obviously had
all the medical stuff going on so I was
like but I'm going to come to your
defense a little bit did you coerce him
into that or was he making a choice and
you were saying this is what I want and
he was not stating what he wanted and
just going along with you no he was
stating what he wanted but I was stating
what I wanted as well and he was like
okay kind of yeah so no one was
comfortable he wasn't strapping up
on the pill and he knew I wanted a baby
so you're nice
I still have seven Flags
maybe throughout the show I'll take one
off we'll see we'll see
Michael your turn all right so um my
toxic relationship uh the girl she was
kind of like knocking me off for my
purpose and um she used to cry on the
phone like she's very emotional and
stuff like that so like oh yeah come see
me and I'm like I've got things to do
and she's all crying and you know it
would make me feel bad and stuff like
that so eventually because of the
arguments and everything we broke up
well I broke up with her but then I kept
smashing her in it
that toxic really yeah
obviously like she wanted me back but it
was just like it was never gonna work
but I'm attracted to her like you know
what I'm saying I like the beat so
obviously I was going back and beating
her and saying nice things like yeah
maybe we might you're doing the yo-yo
thing you're doing the yo-yo thing so
you're like I'm gonna fling your back
but I'm gonna give you some Willy and
bring you back in yeah yeah yeah all of
that so like that was pretty toxic but
that wasn't the most toxic thing I did
though [__] oh God in my life like it
wasn't to her most toxic thing I had a
girlfriend and I slept with two other
girls from POF
bruh in the same day
yeah like same day and then my girl at
the time she wanted to come see me after
but then I was feeling a little bit
guilty so I was like now I'll see you
tomorrow all tired maybe I remember
okay let's have the ladies how many red
flags does Michael get I love I don't
pass a red flag oh yes the ladies
I let the men vote on five five
two girls in one day
she she didn't find out nor did he
insert himself inner to disrespect her
from those interactions I don't think
it's toxic but she don't know she didn't
know
she was in a relationship
so she still thought she was in a
relationship with you sorry and you're
on POF it is yeah yeah it's cheating but
it's not toxic
ity it is cheating but yeah okay giving
a flag for cheating yes one at a time
one at a time she got red flags for
cheating with one person
if you're gonna say cheating cool fact
but it's not toxic well men and women
cheating isn't the same
yeah it's not the same I'm not I still
I'm still giving you red flag Michael
I'm sorry
yeah
because you would have you had a kid so
you're cheap you're cheap you're sad but
yeah but you're cheating as a mother
he's just cheating as like like you're
kind of single till you're married to be
honest I wasn't married then though she
wasn't married do you have a kid I had a
kid I mean your mother
quotes
So you married him after all this yes
were you even attracted to the Sugar
Daddy was you really attracted to him
really no he's the resources though that
actually makes it even worse like he
wasn't even attracted to him you just
slept with him just for the peace he
wasn't ugly
so you basically wait wait wait wait
wait so you basically were a hooker
I
enjoyed this guy so he was an escort
a classy hooker yeah that's good
but you also got money you paid for your
services
well you took it he had
the hooker's job did you
do it he has a good personality okay
was dating him behind my oh God it's
getting worse another flag
[Laughter]
can I have some water please yeah is
there any water I definitely need water
there's girls doing this and they're
painful then Michael now tell me the
most crazy thing that she did that she
did uh well actually recently she's been
calling me from private number she
called me 21 times this is recently yeah
I have a question when's the last time
you slept with her
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so does how many red flags
does Michael get right now right now
he's at five uh
going back and forth I think it's toxic
I think it is how many how many flags
does he get well as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible